This is gonna be fun.
We're setting. Ha.
Swung a little wide there.
Well, aren't we a tall glass of water?
Me? I'm more of a Hawaiian punch.
I'm guessing you don't fight much
outside of your car now, do you?
Look clown.
I don't need four wheels to kick your ass
Any chance we can get this back in
the cars?
How about a little cue music?
Dumps like
a truck. Truck, Truck.
Thighs like. What? What?
What? All night long.
Let me see that thong.
Like it when the beat go,
Baby, let your booty go.
Donna.
Girl, you want a show?
Donna. Donna. Thong, thong, thong, thong.
Do you love the silver haired God?
Don't lie to me.
Yeah, man. Look, I listened to Unleash
the Dragon so many times, the disc
broke. I'm not a liar.
You said you were coming to my show.
Didn't you?
Shot at me? It was a misunderstanding.
I've been getting shot at ever since I
can remember. It's force habit, I
guess.
Sounds like you have trust issues.
You're not wrong. Nice pipes, dude, I
have to say, that high note is perfect.
Oh word?
Yeah. Can I go?
I got somewhere to be.
Thought you said you were coming to the
show.
Of course I am.
Just. Can I leave after the show?
Oh.
Well, in that case, tonight is opening
night.